bitcoin's price has fallen 70 or so uh
it's falling you know 80 85 in past bear
markets at the same time that the prices
falling off a cliff it seems like many
of the underlying fundamentals hash rate
uh lightning node capacity uh lightning
network everything continues to kind of
move up into the right somewhere at
all-time highs or somewhere near
all-time highs how do you balance
price movement and then the underlying
fundamentals decoupling over the last
couple of months in the bitcoin
ecosystem
yeah i guess it's a mix of
uh
bleed through from the wider financial
system so some people will have leverage
on their
stock portfolios and getting margin
calls and so you get a phenomenal where
sometimes people sell
the uh more readily liquid part of their
portfolio
first and so sometimes that's that's
affected bitcoin
and then the you know the more recent
development
was uh leveraging in the
uh defy
part of the space
um
where it turned out uh sort of more
um you know cross-correlated
lending and
precipitated by the lunar collapse of
course
but other people exposed to that and
then three areas capital
having issues
and companies that turned out had made
unsecured lands to three arrows
when you think about whether it's luna
terra ust um or many of these other kind
of high leverage uh or altcoin uh
focused issues that are playing on the
market right now how intertwined is
bitcoin in that is bitcoin just at the
uh um kind of uh whim of what goes on in
the rest of the market or can bitcoin
actually break away be immune somehow
separate itself
well i mean it is uh you know it's
connected in the sense that
uh it's you know it's it's the
investable asset class
and so
you know there's a lot of bitcoin that
gets used
for
um
collateral in d5 platforms via raps
bitcoin and other kind of wrapped
mechanisms
um
but in terms of
the exposure to bitcoin in the drawdown
actually if you look at the bitfinex
dominance index it jumps 20
you know towards bitcoin dominance
during the uh the price adjustment so
that's to say that you know
bitcoin is down but the alts as a basket
are down a lot more and so have a you
know very high percentage growth
to get back to they were they were if if
they in fact they will i think you know
historically
most of all coins have reached a high
point against bitcoin and then
individually
never recoup that position again
when you start to look at uh leverage in
the market we recently talked to caitlyn
long and
she was talking about her efforts to
build kind of a different type of
financial institution out in wyoming how
do you think about bitcoin's ability to
incentivize people not to pursue
what many would consider the traditional
banking model which is rehypothecation
uh and high leverage
yeah well i mean i think some you know a
number of people and funds will have
learnt some hard lessons in you know in
pull down from
30 to 20 particularly that seems to tip
some things over or trigger some things
so
you know i mean
it transpires and of course it was
disclosed and suspected that
many of the lending platforms were
rehypothecating that is to say you know
somebody would take a bitcoin
collateralized loan so they would put up
you know let's say
one bitcoin and borrow half a bitcoin
worth of dollars
assuming that the bitcoin was having a
screw but that's not actually what was
happening the the bitcoins put up as
collateral
were either in part or fully
relent to hedge funds doing high risk
things with them such as
you know uh presumably the strategies of
three areas capital and others were
doing
and so the
the sort of re-hypothecation
by the lending platforms in some cases
you know obviously don't want to paint
them all with the same brush because the
risk
management is quite different between
these firms and some of them do no
rehabilitation like huddle huddle is you
know multi-sages grow you can look at
the coins not moving on chain because
you have one of the keys
um
but the unsecured re-lending
is sort of exposing the borrower to to
risk that they probably didn't
understand or expect to be taken